meanwhile lots of drama in the life with
Real Housewife of New York Bethenny
Frankel her divorce a mysterious health
scare she got it all over with our
Jeffrey parents have a couple of
different female issues going on at the
same time that have created kind of the
perfect storm so I am dealing with it
she does have something to celebrate the
end of paying estranged husband Jason
Hoppy twelve thousand dollars a month in
spousal support however the three-year
bitter divorce still isn't final they're
still fighting over property and one is
this gonna be over because I feel like
this has just been such a big chunk of
your life it's been the by far by far
the most difficult thing I have ever
been through I mean it was really brutal
it's not over but when it is over we're
gonna party like it's 1999 it is hunting
season the Real Housewives of New York
are back for their eighth season on
Wednesday and it looks like the
Skinnygirl mogul and new housewife Jules
Wainstein have friction from the start
the two of you seem to butt heads just a
little bit you can come and do the
lion's den but just know there's a lion
in there we see you in the first episode
on a date for the first time in a long
time so were you hesitant to put your
love life back on TV I didn't put my
love life on TV because I'm not in love
it was just very natural
you